[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports aujourd'hui le jour de la
saint valentin et de l'enregistrement de
cette émission nous allons parler
d'amour du sport et plus précisément du
sport local yvelinois quatre
chroniqueurs vont m'accompagner
aujourd'hui dans cette émission
présentation en musique et avec beaucoup
d'amour
aujourd'hui on commence à ma droite
c'est le serial lover de cette émission
il a plus de conquêtes que julio
iglesias et tout cela en étant cyclistes
comme quoi le cyclisme peut rendre sexy
le capitaine il est marié du cos de
vélizy 78 avec nous ça oui alors serial
lover en ont pas dire non quand on voit
pas validé vous êtes modestes n'ont pas
validé alors voilà non valide pas
éveiller j'en connais qui vont pas être
d'accord pour vous c'est quoi la saint
valentin à la saint valentin pour moi
c'est non c'est non fait pas aujourd'hui
que même si même si ce soir on va faire
un petit truc mais c'est vrai que non je
ne cautionne pas du tout vous avez votre
opinion on la respecte
on passe de l'autre côté musical
symbolise à elle seule la saint valentin
les labours à l'élégance elle et la
volupté elle et la sensualité notre
ambassadrice de charme et l'aide de la
grange spécialiste du pôle d'annecy est
avec nous sur ce bateau comment
allez-vous et l'oeil et va très bien
très bien très bien cher à vie alors
j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous une rose
merci beaucoup pour la saint valentin
est bien partie elle va rester près de
moi pendant l'émission à laquelle tintin
merci beaucoup de rien alors vous êtes
la spécialiste du pole dance excuse et
des conseils pour les valentin ou les
valentins qui veulent faire plaisir
éventuellement à vous appeler
alors on passe de l'autre côté un
musique il est lui aussi un symbole de
la saint valentin il se donne corps et
âme pour l'élu de son coeur et pour sa
passion le rugby et ils se battraient
pour ces deux causes tel un gladiateur
notre recette quoi nous pierre
chevallier du rugby-club de versailles
est avec nous pierre de bonheur à tous
et aux lakers vous avez une heure sur le
téléphone web a rappelé hélène bibeau
rappel vous pouvez discuter à la fin de
l'émission ensuite office ont interdites
de l'autre côté à musique lui aussi est
un bourreau des coeurs ses atouts
séduction son humour qui les fait toutes
craquer sa coupe de cheveux très sobre
il arrive à se faire passer pour fabien
barthez depuis 1998 la légende le mythe
coach jean miss ex-entraîneur de plaisir
est avec nous vos sorts quand allez-vous
jean ab très bien très très bien vous
avez prévu quoi vous présente un petit
restaurant et que madame voilà c'est
classique mais mais ça fait toujours
plaisir
c'est important pour vous cette fête non
non non non je ne suis pas trop pour lui
fait comme ça où s'impose et j'attends
palace avait la sémantique comme vous
oui oui non j'attends palacin valade des
mois pour 90 tic
après j'ai quelques petits conseils je
voulais parce que vous avez devant mener
pour la pole dance il oublié de tenir la
barre et pour le cyclisme sol de la
scène après sinon vous allez voir se
balader spa sera big jo miss est en très
grande forme aujourd'hui on vous garde
sur ce plateau direction villepreux
avant de passer au programme de
l'émission un invité de marque était
début février dans la commune lance un
kick boxeur professionnel français
aujourd'hui acteur jérôme le banner est
venu donner pour la première fois un
stage de pieds poings à une quarantaine
d'élèves au gymnase alain mimoun il est
resté au total trois heures sur place
pour leur apprendre des techniques de
combat
ce sportif d'un mètre quatre-vingt-dix
pour cent vingt kilos de muscles sur le
mail the bulldog of normandie et au
micro de notre journaliste d'un mètre
soixante marylène et yapi chaussures
nommé le chihuahua de bordeaux comme
sont habitués à une certaine technique
qui se rapproche plus à lui
ce pape et de l'aqueduc arrêté de la
défense moi je sais plus ce côté on va
dire eux s'attendent à voir une
mitraillette et moi je veux avoir le
bazooka
donc c'est bien d'avoir de deux ans - il
faut après que ça germe dans le dans la
tête du professeur le répéter répéter en
fait celui ci nous c'est un peu le sport
dans toutes les disciplines
il faut répéter répéter répéter révisé
et réparé
il ya déjà eu une réaction je suis pas
super fan des sports de combat
j'ai pas dire c'est en effet en larmes
mais quand on pratique son sport on est
toujours très très content de pouvoir
rencontrer des idoles et en effet jérôme
le banner fait partie des idoles de son
sport et des gens qui ont marqué ce
sport
je me souviens d'un de ses coûts même si
je pas fan de sports de combat le soin
de ses combats ou d'affiner que le bras
cassé et il avait dû abandonner parce
que ces décès des tours c'est des
tournois sur une journée où ils font
plusieurs combats combat il n'a pas pu
finir la finale enfin son adversaire et
profiter de la blessure sur le bras de
demi-finale pour pour continuer
d'attaquer d'attaqué dessus voilà c'est
c'est un vrai personnage c'est un très
gros sportif très grand sportif je pense
qu'une grosse condition physique et un
gros mental
maintenant l'histoire de combat j'ai
quand même du mal et voilà c'est tout
est bon même si le lucky one étant une
discipline une discipline formidable
hélène qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de
jérôme le banner qui a enseigné sa
discipline à des élèves alors des
amateurs alors déjà contre vence dit
qu'on aimerait pas trop le croisé et
avoir un problème avec cela dit
je pense que oui comme disait yann c'est
une chance de pouvoir rencontrer les
personnes qui performent les idoles
comme tu le lises et après il ya
l'expérience et tout ça donc qui vient
partager et c'est évidemment un modèle
après dans sa discipline donc c'est une
chance autant en profiter quand c'est
possible ils le font pas tous donc de
ceux de se rapprocher vraiment des
personnes qui j'allais dire qu'ils
commencent qui sont pas vraiment
professionnel et se mélanger comme ça
c'est il a bien raison de le faire
moi je suis plutôt d'accord bien
chevalier il ya deux points qui
m'inspire la canton après interview
comme celui ci je trouve que c'est un
sportif qui gère bien sa carrière c'est
à dire que c'est son image
la carrière des dans le sport de combat
peut être peut être plus ou moins longue
ça dépend des ça dépend des blessures ça
dépend de l'intensité des commandes des
combats et surtout en témoigne notamment
mais c'est un c'est un sportif qui a
bien bien j'allais dire presque
monétiser son image et et puis là il a
fait quelques passerelles notamment au
cinéma et autres à quelques quelques
figurations je me souviens aussi dans
plus ou moins rude échec du coup loi du
col ou de gaulois voilà dans les
adaptations de bd d'astérix qu'ils
puissent quand même malgré tout malgré
sa consacrer un peu de temps pour venir
au contact du sport régional et
départemental c'est une bonne chose ça
prouve au moins qu'il n'a pas qu'il n'a
pas galvaudé toutes les valeurs du sport
quel que soit le sport en l'occurrence
et et que dès que des jeunes et des
moins jeunes puissent en profiter c'est
une bonne chose
genre il faudrait qu'ils reviennent on
va cesser c'est très très bien pu seront
pas dire de mal de lui parce qu'il est
alors suivre donc
non mais c'est très bien un sportif de
satrapes disciplines confondues
lorsqu'ils se déplacent dans des clubs
et c'est toujours magique c'est toujours
magnifique outre outre le fait qui peut
enseigner des choses et des choses à aux
gens présents mais en plus il ya l'image
qui est là ça c'est très important dans
n'importe quel club dans n'importe
quelle discipline lorsqu'on a un grand
sportif de sa discipline qui se déplace
il ne faut pas tout ce que quelqu'un a
dit donc il faut le saluer c'est bien et
c'est bien il faut il faut même le
répéter c'est très très bien yann
rapidement rapidement parce que en plus
on voit sur les images que il a quand
même mouillé le maillot parce qu'il n'a
pas enfin quand on voit sur wii mais bon
ils pourraient ces trois heures juste
discuter et là il est là quand même
il a qu'à - le maillot il a il il a
vraiment participer je pense que les la
quarantaine de personnes qui ont pu
participer au traitement vraiment bien
apprécié le latéral des changes mais je
sens et c'est sûr et certain
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler à football l'équipe de
football de trappes est toujours
invaincu dans ce championnat de r3 nous
ferons également un coup de projecteur
sur le combat de boxe 2 marvin petit en
belgique
l'élan courtois tentera de remporter un
titre européen mais avant de développer
ces thèmes on va parler d'eux cyclisme
en cyclisme sur piste la sélection de
l'équipe de france pour les championnats
du monde qui se dérouleront du 27
février au 3 mars en pologne vient de
tomber dans l'équipe de vitesse on
retrouvera chez les garçons les
expérimentés quentin lafargue et michael
d'almeida et grégory baugé
chez les jeunes on retrouvera sébastien
vigier 22 ans et ryan et là le 20 ans du
côté des filles 110 clerc 30 ans et
mathilde de gros 19 ans ont été
sélectionnés
un mélange de jeunesse et d'expérience
voulue par le président de la fédération
française c'était très important pour
moi que cette passation de pouvoir se
fasse sereinement pendant cette
olympiade
c'est ce qui se passe ça veut dire que
nos anciens sont encore bien là vous
voyez sont en lice élections beaucoup
d'entre eux peuvent prétendre être
également à tokyo donc c'est très bien
mais en même temps on sent la génération
suivante qui continue à progresser et
qui est particulièrement active pour
gagner ces places dans les sélections et
cette stimulation elle est au bénéfice
de du résultat global c'est certain
la question sur ce thème cette sélection
vous plaît tel oui ou non un mélange
d'expérience et de jeunesse
oui ou valider hélène tous tes dires
jeunesse et expérience est très bien
après
[Musique]
non mais oui oui après c'est bien aussi
de donner la chance à plusieurs jeunes
d'aller se mesurer et de toute façon si
cette sélection a été faite comme ça
c'est que chacun des participants a des
chances de d'apporter son outil sa
petite pierre à l'édifice et de ramener
des titres donc je pense que c'est la
meilleure sélection qu'a pu être faite
sur le moment sur le genre oui cette
sélection vous plaît expérience parce
que de façon la fédération sol est lancé
dans le grand bain c c java
oui oui mais ce n'est pas tout de suite
il n'y a qu'un c'est pas tout nouveau là
il ya quatre ans iso bien participer à
des grandes compétitions déjà mais la
fédération c'est un petit peu réfléchir
c'est le dtn a réfléchi énormément pour
cette sélection
ar je me souviens à une époque comme se
demander si les initiés il fallait pas
laisser au placard les laisser il y
avait un problème de comportement de
mentalité et puis la même fin de compte
on s'aperçoit qu'on a une sélection qui
est très homogène avec d'un côté des
jeunes pleins de talent et l'autre côté
a fait de l'autre côté je connais cette
équipe plutôt d'aider des anciens des
haïtiennes qui ont eu des titres et qui
ont l'expérience pour mener à bien cette
compétition donc pour moi c'est très
bien nativement janin 22 ans sébastien
vigier 20 ans pour rayonner la halle et
19 ans pour 110 clair pour mathilde leur
pardon
c'est donc c'est quoi ces jeunes bien
dujarrier eux marqué non j'ai buggé sur
le nom du champion du monde en titre de
vitesse individuelle était prévient
pourtant le nom de revient pas le nom
vous revient pas je sais que c'est
l'australien mais voilà ça s'arrête là
comme d'habitude j'ai jamais trop pour
moi c'est idéal
voilà ça fait ça fait plusieurs années
que je dis qu'il faut que des hommes
comme grégory baugé transmettre aux plus
jeunes
son expérience son expérience et
d'assurer un championnat du monde il va
vraiment pouvoir les accompagner
je pense que si aujourd'hui ils sont
sélectionnés c'est que déjà sur les
entraînements et les choses qui se
passent entre eux là je pense qu'il ya
une très belle équipe
pour moi tous les sélectionnés le sont
et ils sont justifiés jeu grégory baugé
revient à un très bon niveau et fait des
très bons chronos sur le premier tour de
la vitesse par équipes vous très
important il affrontait 34
et alors il est en fin de carrière je
vais vous dire la même chose que
d'habitude
sir chris hoy a été champion olympique à
36 ans voilà donc
donc pour moi il n'y a aucun souci à 34
ans d'être encore d'être encore
compétitif sur sur une épreuve de sprint
ces audiences j'ai encore moi gagner un
dixième et demi sur sur mon meilleur de
sens donc à 42 ans donc qu'à gori à 34
encore en gagner deux sans aucun souci
non pour moi c'est pas un c'est pas un
problème
surtout qu'on sait en plus que greg est
un vrai guerrier et un vrai combattant
parce que sur l'image de vitesse oui il
faut être rapide mais en plus il faut
être tactique et c'est vrai que greg à 7
à cette qualité là et gorille baugé ryan
et la halle est le seul à avoir réglé
deux heures pour le champion merci à la
régie donc ryan et l'aller le seul à
avoir réussi à prendre une manche en
coupe du monde à matthew d'edr justement
est pas une manche sur un 8e de finale
où un quart de finale il l'a fait en
demi finales sur l'avant dernière coupe
du monde je crois donc pour moi c'est
voilà il a mérité sa place et il mérite
d'être sélectionné pour participer à ce
championnat du monde
même s'il est très jeune il a il a tout
juste 20 ans sébastien ligier a fait une
très grosse saison sur toutes les coupes
du monde avec des demies aider
les places pour pour aller jouer des
podiums et garonne et des médailles sur
les coupes du monde nous voilà c'est on
pouvait pas prendre d'autre on peut pas
prendre d'autres personnes façon parce
qu'on est limité par des quotas quand
quand ils font des sélections moi je
trouve ça je trouve ça très très bien et
je leur souhaite une belle réussite
sébastien m'a glissé qui s'il revenait
avec moins de deux médailles il serait
déçu on verra ça donc voilà une semaine
pierre chevallier qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais de la venue de là le retour
de grégory baugé
moi je le rappelle dix fois champion du
monde je trouve que l'on le si on
compare par deux par rapport à d'autres
sports et on souffre trop justement des
équipes qui sont pas cohérentes et qui
sont pas homogènes commis les gens là on
a un alliage absolument à priori
peut-être unique de rentrer l'expérience
est là et la jeunesse et la fougue de
deux jeunes
jeunes filles jeunes garçons qui sont
qui sont en plein développement donc je
trouve que c'est une très bonne une très
bonne cohérence dans la constitution de
l'équipe
et là ça a été dit autour de cette table
c'est c'est justement 1,12 à liège entre
entre les années les années de
championnat
championnats du monde de grands
événements et puis la fougue et la
recherche d'expériences qui va justement
pouvoir être
être fait à travers la transmission
d'expériences de baugé 110 claire matip
de gros ça peut fonctionner c'est
toujours un peu difficile alors mais
j'ai quand même beaucoup de mal à
compenser par oui mais je sais pas si
j'ai toujours beaucoup de mal à
comprendre la tactique est mise en place
par l'équipe de france sur la vitesse
individuelle de la vitesse par équipes
chez les filles
je vois toujours matt hill qui prend
énormément de deux distances sur le sur
le départ par rapport à par rapport à
110 et elle revient rarement sur sur la
fin du deuxième tour du premier tour
pardon voilà maintenant je juge pas il
ya d'autres nations qui font exactement
la même chose donc je suis pas assez je
suis passé connaisseurs sur cette
discipline qui est vraiment particulière
parce qu'elles ne sont que deux au
départ et donc c'est un peu c'est très
bizarre
voilà je suis pas sûr qu'ils arrivent
encore à ramener deux médailles toutes
les deux sur sur la vitesse la vitesse
la vitesse par équipes maintenant voilà
c'est notre deux seules représentantes
c'est les deux seuls qu'on en a qui sont
au niveau mondial
quand même parce que
d autres sont sont plus fortes mais mais
bon elles sont elles font partie des
cinq six meilleures équipes au monde
donc c'est déjà c'est déjà très bien et
donc elles méritent leur sélection
maintenant il manque un petit il manque
un petit truc est ce que c'est
mathilde qui qui qui qui qui pèse
vraiment sur sur le démarrage ou est-ce
que c est ce que ces 110 qui n'est pas
assez rapide pour pouvoir emmener
mathilde je sais pas ça je peux pas
l'analyse aimé mais bon pour moi c'est
pareil c'est justifié quelle qu'elle
soit elles ont fait leur elles ont fait
toutes les faims beaucoup de coupe du
monde et est toujours avec des résultats
réguliers ya pas deux et pas de problème
tu parler de quotas de valeur sûre de la
sélection c'est je les ai pas tous mais
c'est vrai que sur un tournoi de vitesse
dont on peut inscrire que deux ou trois
participants sur un kilomètre on peut en
mettre que deux donc voilà c'est rien
que par rapport au vivier que et surtout
que ce sont des disciplines ou 20 km
heure n'est pas un n'est pas quelqu'un
qui fait de la vitesse
et pourtant ce sont des épreuves de
sprint mais mais c'est vrai que ça veut
dire que par rapport aux viviers
l'équipe de france ya comme des garçons
qui sont restés sur la touche
et donc on ne peut pas toucher doivent
regrouper derrière je sais peut être
passionné par votre sport en tout cas
ces nouveaux ont la fierté de porter ce
maillot de l'équipe de france nous avons
eu en interview le jeune ryan et la
halle en écoute force cascades mieux en
équipe de france on peut demander à
n'importe qui dans la rue ils sont du
pur où l'équipe de france est allée le
meuse de chaque discipline c'est
ouais c'est le graal c'est on représente
la france
pour un championnat du monde c'est
quelque chose de meaux jean c'est beau
cette fierté de porter le maillot de
l'équipe de france
heureusement peuvent être le contraire
toutes disciplines porter le maillot de
l'équipe de france c'est l'aboutissement
de du travail et d'une carrière c'est
peut-être pas au foot mais sinon après
les autres disciplines les autres
disciplines c'est voilà tout le monde
rêve tout sportif normalement constitué
rêve de porter un jour les couleurs de
l'équipe de france donc jeunes comme ça
il est c'est bien c'est très très bien
en plus
très très bien ça les motive encore plus
à votre avis ln oui c'est
l'aboutissement finalement de leur
carrière ou le début mais en fait c'est
ça c'est que c'est l'aboutissement oui
c'est je pense que c'est un but à
atteindre c'est une fierté mais la
teinte si jeune c'est extraordinaire tu
vas t'en dormir non c'est vrai
alors j'aimerais qu'on revienne par
contre sur une absence on n'en a pas
parlé jusque là l'absence de françois
pervis qui a emporté qui à 34 ans qui a
remporté sept titres de champion du
monde françois pervis n'est pas dans
cette liste pour la première fois depuis
une dizaine d'années yann jerry comment
vous l'analysez 7
cette non sélection de demandes servi
manque de résultats de performance
manque de performance ce qui fait qu'il
a été mis à l'écart de l'équipe de
france aujourd'hui françois s'entraînent
dans des conditions très très compliqué
ils savaient qu'ils ne seraient pas au
championnat du monde cette année
depuis depuis un bon moment c'est pour
moi c'est pas fini un petit peu dans mon
esprit que grégory il ya deux trois ans
françois et est largement capable et le
mental pour pouvoir revenir
il s'entraîne très dur il s'entraîne
tout seul de son côté comme il a souvent
fait et comme ils l'aiment
il va il va de toute façon continue de
jouer de jouer sa carte et il faudra se
méfier de lui au championnat de france
parce que ben pour lui est un petit peu
dans le même esprit que sandie clair
après les jeux olympiques
il va falloir qu'il ne repasse pas les
championnats de france pour montrer
qu'il est compétitif et qui est capable
de prendre la place d'autres et ensuite
revenir sur des coupes du monde où il
devra à nouveau démontré ses capacités
pierre chevalier est ce que finalement
c'est et françois pervis ou grégory
baugé tous les horizons 34 ans sur le
pedigree de l'auto et dun rappelle
d'animaux et oui c'était 7 et à pile ou
face à ce moment là et ça se joue sajou
a priori sur ce que diane ça se joue sur
les résultats et sur leur sur la forme
du moment après on compare de cv et puis
après on compare encore par d'autres
jobs finalement de job actuel
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec je ne
suis pas d'accord parce que oui ce sont
deux très grands champions et bien sûr
mais en fait ils sont sur deux postes
complètement différent grégory et
démarreur sur la vitesse sur la vitesse
par équipes et c'est lui et ses
meilleurs aujourd'hui dans l'équipe de
france à le faire
françois a été testé et n'avait pas eu
d'aussi bons résultats mais françois
aurait pu être vue que françois a été
champion du monde du kilomètre il a été
champion du monde du keirin
il aurait pu être sur d'autres
disciplines aussi dans le dans le sprint
mais ces résultats à l'entraînement le
s'étend à l'entraînement ne font qu il
n'a pas pu ne permet pas d'aller
chercher la place voilà c'est ça mais
grégory est là parce que il a réussi à
apprendre les meilleures départ de tous
les français
sur le premier tour de la vitesse des
vitesses par équipes on va refermer
cette thématique
avant de refermer cette thématique
combien de médailles à votre avis pour
vous
je ne vais pas du tout avancé là dessus
il ya eu deux médailles de bronze
l'année dernière lors dé ce qu'on fera
mieux cette année à votre avis voilà
gilles faire mieux pour moi il ya aucun
problème puisque je vois bien sébastien
revenir avec deux trois médailles je peu
près sûr que l'équipe de vitesse par
équipe reviendra haussière avec une
médaille une médaille par équipes
mathilde devrait aussi revenir avec une
médaille minimum sur le keirin puisque
c'est quand même les preuves qui lui va
le mieux de mieux aujourd'hui elle est
quand même championne du monde
championne d'europe en titre
donc voilà oui il y aura des y aura des
médailles aura des titres et puis après
et apprendre
oui mais oui parce qu'il ya aussi les
l'endurance il ya une paire avec brian
avec eux car bryan coquard et puis sur
l'américaine
ils vont revenir un costaud planète
serait il un côté aurélien avec avec
regret pas été encore définis dans mais
c'est parce que je sais pas ce que j'ai
lu j'ai pas retenu mais j'ai passé parce
que j'avais lu mais voilà est pareil
l'équipe de poursuite par équipe est
capable de faire de faire de belles
choses
donc n'en aurait plus de 5 autour de
cinq médailles on peut être plus de cinq
médailles ou à ses joueurs on vous garde
liane pour parler encore cyclisme une
course inédite s'est déroulée au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la structure
accueilli ce lundi 2 février une
compétition d'une durée de six heures au
total 24 équipes de quatre coureurs se
sont affrontés à coup de pour
soulever la coupe
il fallait parcourir le plus de
kilomètres dans le temps imparti on
l'écouté l'un des organisateurs jean
michel richefort il faut trouver les
bons temps sur la piste pas s'est
déroulé entre
30 minutes 45 minutes passent et un
relais lorsque le concurrent est fatigué
emplissent alors il ya toute une travée
une stratégie à adopter
et puis marquer aussi ses adversaires à
la fin des six heures c'est l'équipe du
paris cycliste olympique qui remporte la
compétition avec 1060 tours parcourus
sur la première heure les pistes ont
réussi à atteindre une moyenne de 50
km/heure ces six heures ont été
organisées quelques jours seulement
après la finale de la coupe d'hiver de
cyclisme sur piste qui s'est déroulé
pendant deux mois avec plusieurs étapes
tout au long des deux mois la question
sur ce thème le vélodrome nationale at
il trouvé son rythme de croisière par
rapport au cyclisme
l'organisation de compétitions cyclistes
de partager vous avez vu motivé quand
vous avez pris votre petite pancarte we
live in an et j'ai eu six 6 il saisit
j'ai mis non tout simplement parce que
sans vouloir jeter la pierre à
l'organisation des six heures c'est à
dire c'est très très bien mais par
contre on ne peut pas dire que ce soit
une compétition de grande envergure donc
mettre ça dans les organisations en dix
ans on a trouvé le rythme de croisière
pour le vélodrome
j'espère et je souhaite qu'il y ait
autre chose comme en compétition pour
faire vivre et ce vélodrome quand on
voit le nombre de spectateurs qui
avaient à cet événement c'est pas comme
ça qu'on va attirer les fonds bien
regardé des gradins du tout sur la piste
ah ben oui heureusement parce que sinon
il n'y a pas de compétition et sa
personne sur la piste ce qui s'appelle
vélodrome vide est là
non mais pour moi non pour moi pour moi
c'est pas et passe avec ce genre de
compétition comme peut dire qu'on va
faire vivre le vélodrome avec le
cyclisme pierre chevallier dans le sport
amateur comme dans le sport
professionnel il ya une vraie différence
entre les pratiquants et les spectateurs
que ça attire donc sur ce point là je
pense pas que le vélodrome et et trouvé
son rythme de croisière à attirer
suffisamment de spectateurs sur le sur
le cyclisme on en a souvent parlé ici
d'ailleurs la diversification des
activités fait en sorte que justement
cet espace puissent être ouverts le plus
le plus souvent possible et essayer
d'attirer une des nouveaux publics et
des noëls audiences mais effectivement
il ya plus de monde sur le centre de la
piste que que dans les gradins donc il
ya un an il ya sûrement encore du boulot
pour intéresser régulièrement et de
manière pérenne les spectateurs à venir
voire du cyclisme ou d'autres événements
dans ce dans cette grande enceinte vient
déjà de plus fait des compétitions
internationales finalement c'est pour
ces pour sceller la raison par etienne
j'ai dit j'ai dit non tout simplement
c'est parce que il n'ya pas voilà on a
là riblon un rythme de croisière sur sur
les événements de l'hiver pour le
cyclisme régional
voilà la dca coupe d'hiver s'est mis en
place il rajoute une épreuve de six
heures qui est qui est ouvert au monde
amateur et donc c'est très bien
régulièrement on a quelques pros qui
viennent justement si sur les sur les
épreuves de coupe de coupes d'hiver donc
là dessus c'est super parce que
justement ça permet aussi aux plus
jeunes de rencontrer des des champions
et des des professionnels maintenant en
effet il manque
il manque une
une belle compétition tous les ans qui
qui permettrait de montrer un spectacle
d'envergure internationale alors voilà
il ya eu des projets tout a capoté
tout est toujours tombé à l'eau si bien
laisser guider je ne peux pas avoir les
championnats du monde tous les ans ou
les championnats d'europe tous les ans
c'est pas possible là d'ailleurs j'ai
appris que
le vélodrome avait posé sa candidature
pour 2022 je pense que comme on va
organiser les jeux jeux comme on voir et
des jambes et les jeux olympiques en
2024 ya de grandes chances que le
vélodrome soit retenu pour pour 2022
ça permet de faire une répétition deux
ans avant les deux ans avant les jeux
olympiques donc complètement logique il
se serait ce serait très très bien
maintenant petit
petit voilà il manque il manque un truc
tous les ans une classe une classe une
ici ou une révolution série quelque
chose qui amènerait du spectacle mais à
chaque fois qu'ils ont essayé de faire
quelque chose il n'y a jamais eu public
qui a répondu qui a répondu présent donc
donc ces problématiques
en tout cas qu'ils vont organiser des
cours un championnat international dont
j'étais là du monde le chef je suis je
suis pas inquiet il n'y a pas besoin de
communiquer ça se remplira tout seul
voilà c'est mais c'est sur le reste il
faut qu'il faut faire qui vous faire un
gros forcing parce que cette ce sport et
et des très très très vu en angleterre
et à chaque fois qu'il ya un an chez les
anglo saxons
chaque fois qu'un événement c'est
toujours foule l'a lâché nous on a un
souci le tour de france prend trop de
place
on va maintenant orange et des vélos
yens dujarrier pour parler football dans
notre page résultat on prend la
direction du championnat de régionale 3
1 but a suffi à leur bonheur les
trappistes ont assuré l'essentiel ce
dimanche 10 février en s'imposant 1 à 0
à domicile face à paresi on voit le but
à l'image regarder une frappe en lucarne
magnifique on écoute les réactions on a
réussi à développer un jeu assez porte
aux ducks ont bondi parce que les
terrains ne permettait pas trop mais ça
a été un peu le but il nous a vraiment
libérés du coup après on a essayé de
poser la balle pour jouer un match
engagé puisque un terrain à la limite du
praticable mais un bon match dans
l'ensemble
là on a su respecter les consignes qui
était donné et une victoire 1-0 qui me
semble méritée
à neuf journées de la fin du championnat
trap est toujours invaincu avec la
meilleure défense l'équipe pointe à la
deuxième place de régionale 3 on va
prendre les matches les uns après les
autres à la fin son dernier sprint y a
quelque chose à jouer à jouer band
jouera à fond dans l'objectif ses trois
matches après les autres les uns après
les autres je pense qu'en restant solide
on sera une place intéressante en fin de
saison alors on va voir le classement
trappe et on est donc deuxième du
championnat de régionale 3 et ne sont
pas loin de la place de leader
comme vous pouvez le voir à l'écran
saint-ouen pointe à seulement un petit
point des trappistes la question sur ce
thème est-ce que tu rappes pourrait se
satisfaire de terminer la saison
invaincus et juste invaincu c'est à dire
pas de montée en fin de saison
oui ou non non pas de débat non plus
pierre chevalier
non parce que c'est là où là aussi où
l'appétit vient en mangeant on parle je
précise quand même que le dans
l'histoire du club ça ne s'est jamais
réalisé des travaux d'être invaincu
pendant toute une saison
ça sera dit ça serait déjà un c'est un
fait d'armes mais mais en gros l'ailé
quand on démarre une saison en règle
générale on se fixe des objectifs qui
sont les objectifs des objectifs de
compétition il ya deux de monter ou
d'éviter la descente pour certaines
équipes auxerre des certaines années la
cerise sur le gâteau c'est de terminer
invaincue pour un sport que je connais
bien une équipe que je connais bien
c'est ce qui est en train de nous marier
mais mais le premier objectif c'est
c'est justement d'atteindre un objectif
sportif qui est d'atteindre une division
supérieure ou de se maintenir quelques i
quel qu'il soit est en fait c'est la
différence entre le l'objectif est la
manière la attendent la montée en étant
invaincu là ce serait la saison parfaite
c'est ce qu'il faut qui est ce qu'il
faut qui vise donc donc
donc il ne pourrait pas se satisfaire
d'être invaincu si ça n'a pas servi à
les faire monter d'accord hélène c'est
pareil je pense qu'on peut pas juste se
contenter d'un
de simplement rester au même niveau et
simplement être invaincus et comme on le
disait sans fin comme tu le disais c'est
soit on monte dans le classement et ça
c'est un vrai progrès soit on reste en
haut du classement et on passe à l'est
en
comment dire en montée sinon d'être en
haut et d'être invaincus je pense qu'on
a une fin oui non c'est ça sauf si les
places ont été chèrement gagnée mais là
ça a pas l'air d'être le cas
en même temps ils sont quatre dans le
voilà c'est ça ils sont quatre à trois
points pour la première à la quatrième
place il y à trois points de différence
donc j'en oublie très très serré pour
moi alors voir le classement
jean est ce que sur les dix dernières
journées ils leur restent center né à
jouer il reste un toit un jouet c'est le
match est décisif
il y aurait également des matchs contre
suresnes et boulogne billancourt qui
sourit tout à fait dans un mouchoir de
poche avec cee-lo reste s'ils leur
restent sur aisne boulogne un goût et
cette donnée a joué à rien n'est fait
parce que rennes est absolument faux
mais il est certain que mathématiquement
si il gagne 6 pour moi ci soit vécue
jusqu'à la fin de la saison à moins
qu'ils fassent que des nuls
il ya ceux qui passeront de mentoring
dracula se fera automatiquement trappe
un bilan de six victoires et 7 nuls
il marque peu treize buts mais ils ont
la meilleure défense je le disais
précédemment et que seulement sept buts
encaissés on peut se satisfaire de ces
chiffres yann annoncé il ya plus de
matches nuls que deux matches gagnés je
dirais que se retrouver se retrouver en
deuxième position avec plus de matches
nuls que deux matches gagnés c'est déjà
un presque un miracle
donc là il faut il faut accélérer et en
effet selon comment ils vont recevoir
quand il marque et marquer des beaux
buts
comme souvent ce sont des 0-0 des 55
députés peu d'acide résultat ça se fait
que tu as s'est joué après est-ce qu'ils
vont aller au blason avec 13 buts en
sept entrées journée est-ce qu'ils vont
se déplacer à suresnes est ce qu'ils
vont aller à boulogne est ce qu'ils vont
aller à saint-ouen c'est pareil là
dessus ça va être ça va être important
et donc
je
il va falloir surveiller parce que en
effet s'il arrive à monter et à élever
le niveau sur sur le sprint final parce
que la vue le mouchoir dans le tennis on
le sprint ne va pas être très courts
c'est un sprint assez long parce que
même si vous faites une un bon résultat
afin elle confirmé derrière ça peut pas
s'arrêter juste un bon résultat donc là
le sprint le sprint des neuf prochains
des neuf prochains matches le sprint
final commence maintenant déjà voilà
pour pour aller chercher là et la
moindre erreur sera fatale
un des 4 1 et 4 alors je vous propose
maintenant de parler de football
américain les templiers d'elancourt ont
enregistré leur troisième victoire en
trois matches dans le championnat de 2e
division
les élans courtois se sont imposés ce
samedi du coup à domicile face au miami
don de savigny-le-temple le score 26 à 7
une victoire qui leur permet de prendre
la tête de la poule b de la conférence
nord on écoute le président des
templiers d'elancourt joël da silva
trois matches trois victoires donc pour
l'instant on est dans ned sur les
objectifs fixés tiède skalli cligner
dans un premier temps pour les play-offs
donc pour l'instant tout sans tous tout
s'emboîte correctement la semaine
prochaine on va à villeneuve d'ascq chez
les vikings du guil donc voilà pour
l'heure son tour tout est en ordre de
marche
la question sur ce thème peut-on déjà
qualifié cette équipe deux rouleaux
compresseurs
oui la partager jarrier pourquoi trois
matches on se souvient qu'ils ont gagné
un premier match qui a été difficile je
vais vous faire l'historique des matchs
cette saison contre les pionniers de
touraine 14 à 13 contre les diables
rouges de villepinte 36 à 0 nouvelle
victoire et 26 à 7 contre l'émir bidon
de savigny on pourrait on pourra voir
dans deux trois matches justement si le
fils
le premier match n'avait été qu'un peu
qu'un tel qu'une alerte et qui se sont
servis de leçon alors encore encore un
ou deux matchs pour pourrait dire en
effet c'est vrai que là il gagne avec
une avait une grosse différence
ils ont bien rattraper ils ont bien
corriger le tir par rapport à ce début
de saison qui avait été très très limite
maintenant si ils arrivent à prendre ce
rite ce rythme de croisière sur les
prochains matches oui ils vont
certainement mais bon c'est pas rien ils
descendent donc là c'est parce et bien
il arrive à mieux rire et à se dire
enfin à aller chercher la division
depuis deux trois ans depuis trois ans
bien d'accord +3 un choix qui
redescendent de dar saad mois de l'année
trop longtemps vous avez dans l'émission
c'est pas politiser le temps passe si
vite
pierre chevalier sont déplacés en trois
matchs en 3 4 3 millions en trois
matches donc il reste environ une
dizaine de matchs simples rapides pour
vous oui en trois matches voilà l écart
et commence à être intéressant c'est ce
que disait s'il reste sur ce sur cette
lancée là et qui confirme des gros
écarts à chaque match on pourra parler
d'un rouleau compresseur mais là trois
matchs sur encore une dizaine qui reste
encore très mature et wissant pour tous
pierre chevallier on vous a vu jouer du
pipeau
ouais moi aussi je trouve cette ligne
très poétique au niveau des titres des
équipes pour ça je trouve ça hyper frais
les pionniers de les médias toros de
villepinte
l'émir de dons de savigny c'est celle là
me plaît beaucoup
cette équipe me plaît beaucoup ce dont
on se souviendra dans le magnéto serge
c'est que on allait parler en tout début
de saison des templiers avec notamment
ce match qui a failli et un match
couperet et puis on retient finalement
plus que la question de rouleau
compresseur pour les qu'il est vraiment
trop tôt pour se prononcer que c'est eux
c'est un match qui les avait lancé et on
avait été très fin dans zones dont un
analyse en ce début de saison en dix ans
là pour le coup il avait un petit peu
peut-être un mot l'homme qui gonflé et
ils se sont bien vite recentré et à
priori ça a été pour le meilleur
puisqu'ils ont gagné tous leurs matchs
en suivant l'a8 évidemment les
téléspectateurs à regarder le replay de
cet ennemi de magnéto et là exactement
le début peut-être que les templiers où
l'on écoute et peut-être dans vos
commentaires vous accorder beaucoup de
crédit
mais en tout cas peut-être mois les
potées je pense qu'ils ont eu surtout
même discours que nous que les coaches
ont eu le même discours que alors je
rappelle quand même que les templiers
même s'ils terminent premiers de leur
poule ne seront pas automatiquement
qualifiés pour la montée il faut donc il
faudrait qu'ils passent par des playoffs
voilà jean ampe direction oui je veux
juste rajouter que à trois journées du
début
si on leur mettait l'étiquette le
rouleau compresseur s'amorce alors à ne
pas servir justement vu la première
journée où il avait failli passer à la
trappe avec un excès de confiance donc
restons humbles et attendant que la
saison 0-0
ils ont fait 36 à 0 sur le deuxième
match contre les mentions bien en tout
cas pour les templiers et langton il va
pas je suis maintenant notre page focus
dans ce focus de la boxe le grand jour
approche pour marvin petit le boxeur de
la team farrugia à elancourt est en
pleine préparation pour aller chercher
un titre de champion d'europe des poids
légers contre le belge francesco à
patera le sportif a enchaîné les mises
de gants et les sessions de haut niveau
pour être fin prêt pour son combat
programmé ce samedi 16 février en
belgique il était au micro de tv 68
je vais confiant parce que je vais
jamais pardon j'aime pas je suis pas un
pardon moi j'y vais j'y vais pas le
détruire c'est pas pour ça va lui faire
du bien comment dire comme on dit chez
nous je suis gitans mais chez nous
partout ici parce que c'est chez lui que
ça y va il va faire un patron il n'y a
pas de n'est pas de ça solo ring
tu es un bonhomme le monde qui autour
têtu calcule pas et tu boxes genre une
réaction par rapport à cette interview
je suis allé chez les fans de petit
j'espère qu'il va y arriver parce que
mais parce qu'ils bossent pour et et qui
mérite pour moi ils le méritent
maintenant après et vous avez dit qu'il
a changé sur le look c'est pas plus mal
je le préférais avant je ne suis pas
pour un boxeur qui change de nom mais je
regarde un petit peu la boxe et je n'ai
jamais vu comme ça je pense ça devait
déjà faire de bruit ces lieux c'est
mieux que c'est fait beau pour son
combat
tant mieux je pense que allez je vais
moi je suis pour lui et je mène ticket
sur lui alors léger avantage pour marvin
petit le sportif de 27 ans affiche pour
le moment un bilan de 24 victoires dont
12 par ko 1 nul et une défaite son
adversaire affiche hui 20 victoires pour
trois défaites
la question sur ce thème est il favori
de cette rencontre sachant que c'est en
belgique
il n'est pas chez lui même si je la
communauté gitane sera présent dans dans
le stade mais souvent on va dire qui
tirait lorsque vous jean et pierre genre
pouvait commencer
alors justement j'avais l'air ambiant
voilà j'aime bien aller juste de
clôturer le dossier et tablier et moi je
le mets pas favorite justement parce que
je ne faut pas qu'ils excèdent eu
d'excès de confiance et lemaitre favori
no 1 et sportif français pour moi c'est
on n'est jamais bon bien donné favori
donc moi je l'aimais pas favori et est
pour moi et pour moi il va gagner pour
moi il va gagner et voilà c'est doux et
non pour moi il ne veut pas le maître
favoris parce qu'on n'est pas bons les
sportifs rasé lorsqu'on est favori on
n'est pas bon on passe le temps à voter
box et non pas de rugby pierre chevalier
mais ces rencontres est notre éminent
chroniqueur de cette émission quand
paraît mieux parce que je vois qui il
s'entraîne aussi avec avec marine c'est
moi je vais dire je le mets favoris
parce que c'est une une question va dire
d'alignement des planètes et peut-être
de moments d'expérience d'entraînement
jean l'a rappelé il bosse pas mal depuis
de nombreuses années on le suit on le
suit dans cette émission sur c'est sur
ces entraînements sur ses combats
là on nous la belgique s'est pas c'est
pas si loin de chez nous c'est pas si
loin de chez lui il a l'air de dire que
la communauté gitane l'accompagnera et
qu'il est partout il est partout chez
lui je crois surtout en dans la vertu de
la vertu de l'entraînement c'est vrai
que le statut le statut de favori ne
réussit pas toujours aux français on
s'est souvent on est souvent tombé tombe
est bien ou quand on nous annonce est
gagnant mais là en l'occurrence sur un
sur un combat à un contre un et sur la
sur le mental et la préparation de
marlene je pense que je pense que là il
peut il doit y arriver c'est le moment
hélène qui vous a convaincu pierre ou
genre jean-pierre non je rejoins ce que
dit jean
quand il parle de voilà des des favoris
qui voilà qui sont pas forcément les
meilleurs performeurs au moment dé des
matchs et des compétitions c'est vrai je
pense qu'il faut garder la tête dans le
guidon et être concentré maintenant
maintenant je pense qu'on sent forcément
dire il est favori ou pas il a mon avis
toutes les toutes les capacités et
toutes les chances donc voilà s'il reste
concentré qui prend pas la grosse tête
et qui sans accompagner et qui y voit là
s'entraîne dans ce but là il ya il ya
possibilité qu'on ait de bons résultats
un point c'est tout un final y'a déjà
rien on vous a pas entendu sur la
question même si elle n'est pas un grand
fan des sports de combat le combat
maintenant voilà à 50 - français à saint
quentinois qui se bagarrent pour une fin
qui combat pour un pour un titre
européen
je ne peux être que derrière lui et
c'est vrai que en plus bon voilà raoult
de connaît on sait que c'est quelque
chose qui lui tient à coeur
il faut il faut qu'ils reviennent avec
de toute façon on veut voir la ceinture
et il n'a pas le choix c'est un bel
avantage qu'il soit à l'extérieur même
si la communauté gitane va l'accompagner
sincères nous avons des minibus qui vont
partir d'elancourt pour les salaires en
belgique autant autant le g des
conditions sûres sur un match à
l'extérieur quand quand on joue en
sports collectifs la sueur sur des
salles de boxe ce sont des arènes un
petit peu
qui évolue on peut très bien faire dans
un vélodrome on peut le faire monter
dans des salles de casino
on peut on peut en faire on peut en
faire un peu un peu partout de la boxe
donc là il n'y a pas de n'y a pas
d'esprit de je suis chez moi je suis
dans mon fief
donc je suis pas sûr que ça justement
ils sont ces quatre mètres sur quatre
mètres pour pouvoir se taper dessus et
puis et puis le meilleur et que le
meilleur gagne et le meilleur sera
marvin une dernière chose que les
supporters sont à l'entente de la
belgique c'est juste à côté
parce que même voilà même si on
déplaçait le match qu'on le faisait
vraiment beaucoup plus loin il y aurait
peut-être un petit peu cette question
dès ce qu'on est suivi supporter et
c'est là on est à trois heures de route
peut-être 4 vous allez y aller avec moi
non mais là je suis pas très sincèrement
je prends tomber une de voir des gens se
taper mais après voilà je pense qu'il
sera largement accompagné suivi et
encouragé le jour j sincèrement quand on
est dans le match quand on est dans le
sprint pour un pour un cycliste les les
spectateurs on les oublie quoi ces onze
on n'y pense plus etc
j'ai déjà fait j'ai déjà fait des
sprints devant 2500 personnes au
vélodrome et c'est pas dans le sprint
c'est juste obsession tour d'après audi
voilà où on est content parce que parce
qu'il y avait du monde mais sur le
moment quand on est quand canton à
l'adversaire en face quand l'arbitré il
a mis deux coups dans la cloche
marvin y pense plus qu'à une chose c'est
à les détruire mais qui a en face de lui
les gens qui crient à côté il les entend
pas même le coach qui lui dit droit de
gauche etc
il n'entend pas il est dans son île et
dans son combat c'est plus possible ces
chercheurs dernière question avant de
passer aux thèmes suivants
ils doivent adopter quelle stratégie en
asie aux pensées stratégie aux fraises
c'est bien il doit il de le mettre ko
rapidement où il doit gérer son match
n'est pas forcément très très bien la
boxe mais je pense qu'il s'est entraîné
pour le prendre à la gorge et puis et
puis s'il peut plier le combat le plus
rapidement possible je pense pas qu'ils
sont privera on va passer maintenant
notre page débats
dans ce débat nous avons parlé
automobile le départ du 4l trophy 2010 9
est programmée le 21 février prochain
depuis biarritz parmi les 2600 étudiants
attendus pour ce raid entre la france et
le maroc
on retrouvera sur la ligne de départ
deux plaisirs oiseau volant de leur 4l
justin series et marianne briel elles
sont prêtes à avaler les 6000 km de
pistes désertiques et de dunes à la
boussole
on les écoute expérience je pense qu'on
va en apprendre beaucoup de cette
aventure au lieu au niveau humain si par
exemple il ya des gens qui sont en
galère ' on se voit un peu s'arrêter
demander qu'est ce qui se passe pour
aider quoi c'est une belle façon de
découvrir le maroc et je pense attendait
une aventure inoubliable
j'espère qu'on aura pas trop galère sur
la route hélène vous avez un petit
commentaire sur la 4l tu as oui c'est
des filles donc la 4l elle est rose en
évidemment voilà ils ont acheté rose en
fait
winch et samedi longueur des routes
parce que la leur leurs plaies après les
mignonnes mais ça tient il ya le côté un
peu il cote un peu girly moi j'espère
qu'elles vont mettre 4 quelques quelques
stickers et quelques décorations voilà
pour la là pour dire la réaliser un peu
voilà c'est ça la cus tournissa
customiser alors bel également que
chaque 4 elle embarquera des fournitures
scolaires pour les enfants 30 tonnes de
matériel sont amenés chaque année dans
la caravane
la question sur ce thème le 4l trophy
est il une vraie compétition sportive
oui ou non
toujours pas ce qu'on attend par sport
aubert ce genre et yen j'ai dit nombreux
genres je vous laisse commencer qu'est
ce que j'ai dit que j'étais un c'était
une compétition sportive dit oui j'ai
l'exil compétitions sportives
car oui c'est du côté de compétition
sportive parce que c'était un rallye et
en connaît la dureté des rallyes donc
pour moi c'est une compétition
aujourd'hui parce que on a souvent ici
sur le plateau le débat du du sport et
qui avec et qu'un effort physique et sur
un rallye il ya un effort l'effort
physique il ya la fatigue il ya les
problèmes le côté nerveux le côté faye
et outillés pour que ça représente
totalement une épreuve sportive à toute
échelle après bon il ya le côté en plus
d'amener des fournitures scolaires donc
caritatif caritatif et senna lent mais
il ya tout pour moi et aucun problème
c'est la dureté du de la compétition
fait que c'est un sport à part à dire
yann et juillet oui alors non ce n'est
pas une compétition sportive
oui c'est un effort sportif mais oui en
fait c'est ça le
oui ça toute la nuance elle est là en
fait et je vais encore me faire des
ennemis comme d'habitude message assume
mais c'est vrai que j'ai ce discours
même quand je suis un repas avec des
amis
c'est vrai qu'il ya une grosse
différence entre entre la compétition et
l'effort physique est en effet là je te
rejoins là dessus et je suis je suis
content mon accord avec avec jean c'est
un vrai effort physique ce type de ce
type de deux raids je peux dire
compétition puisque puisque sans mener
ce n'est pas une objectif est simplement
d'aller au bout et de et de finir et
d'apporter et d'apporter de l'aide à un
pays qui peut en avoir besoin il ya des
enfants qui peuvent en avoir besoin
donc il ya il ya aussi un côté côté
ludique et un côté caritatif qui est
très important maintenant voilà c'est
sûr que les filles quand elles vont
avoir fini elles sont bien contentes
d'être arrivé et je pense qu'elles les
ont besoin de récupérer les dans les
jours qui l aideront des souvenirs car
elles ont des souvenirs plein la tête et
le maroc est un très beau pays donc donc
c'est bien que ça se passe ça se passe
là bas et il faudrait même tu as aille
plus loin parce que parce que ben
l'afrique c'est un pays de rallye raid
et il faut qu' il faut qu'il y ait
d'autres rallyes raid qui reviennent tu
reviennes sur le continent africain
pour ne pas citer sarah semble de toute
façon pas mal de données de données du
sport c'est un objectif c'est là c'est
une équipe ou un binôme c'est c'est un
effort physique c'est un effort mental
c'est un peu de stratégie celi vaillant
a de la mécanique donc là dans le côté
sport mécanique on en rajoute l on peut
des cours de mécanique justement pour
moi c'est la télé 4l pour ça que je te
connais compétition j aurais ri à
conduire là dessus et c'est pas mal
c'est une voiture fantastique c'est
génial de les voir encore en activité
surtout sur les sur les routes du désert
marocain
quand on rajoute en plus à ça une
dimension universelle est une immense
une dimension de promotion et
caritatives en plus dans la tôle gagner
c'est c'est un effort un effort sportif
une compétition sportive qui qui en plus
donne donne donne du bonheur et de
l'utilité en plus dans le dans le projet
je rappelle voilà que cette compétition
et pour les étudiants de 18 à 28 ans de
toutes nationalités vraiment 1204 elles
seront seront au départ
est ce que il ya également les valeurs
de solidarité voilà d'entre aide parce
que c'est une compétition mais en même
temps une compétition avec de
l'entr'aide où les étudiants parfois cdh
a poussé la voiture est ce que c'est la
solidarité finalement l'essence du sport
je pense que en effet on a envie
d'arriver premier il ya toujours la dde
qui ont la gagne comme ça mais comme il
n'y a pas forcément de
on appelle ça de l'ordre d'arrivée de
voilà ce qui compte c'est déjà terminé
et c'est vraiment cette valeur de voilà
d'amener de partage et de voilà de faire
l'épreuve en communauté voilà est
d'arriver au bout c'est vraiment tout ça
qui prime dont je pense que si on a des
choses à apprendre sur à la fois un
sport mécanique à la fois des valeurs de
compétition des valeurs sportives des
valeurs d'entraidé caritatives etc tout
est réuni dans une discipline comme ça
ce sera le mot de la fin sur cette
thématique
on va on leur souhaite évidemment bon
courage pour participer à ce 4l trophy
je rappelle que le départ est programmé
le 21 février depuis biarritz on passe
maintenant notre pas dernière page la
rubrique découverte dans cette tâche
découverte nous allons parler d'un sport
insolite le foot golf une section s'est
créé à saint quentin en yvelines début
septembre par des habitants du secteur
ils sont à l'heure actuelle une
vingtaine présentation de ce sport
hybride fait le football ça c'est simple
c'est à 99% les rives du golfe c'est un
sport hybride
c'est un sport il remettait ça se fait
en fait du coup les règles du golf sauf
qu'on joue avec nos pieds et un ballon
de foot avec des trous qui font 53 cm de
diamètre et du coup après c'est le même
principe pour faire le moins de coups
pour pouvoir le meilleur résultat
possible a fondé à la fin des 18 trous
la question sur ce thème les imeem
peuvent-elles devenir une terre de foot
de golf quand on voit le nombre de golf
qui lie à ici dans les yvelines
[Musique]
vous êtes mitigé à une cellule de
réflexion non mais parce que non parce
que là bon on passe à la flamme et gamme
c'est le football vous savez recettes
bas mais de là
de là
ce que ça explose et qu'on envoie créer
partout je suis pas sûr quand même bon
footballeur belfort oui c'est un fou de
foot golfeur ouais on pourrait prendre
dans les mêmes termes pour jouer au golf
pour les pour les infos pour les novices
comme ça c'est tiger woods par contre
qu'il devait être content qu'il devrait
être totale parce que la taille des
trous beaucoup plus gros ça devrait
s'intéresser au niveau sportif bien sûr
bien sûr que les sports sur ce plateau
j'ai serré voire quelques années j'étais
très sceptique sur cette discipline
populiste sur la partie golf en disant
mais qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on va
mélanger de sport comme comme sociaux
ces deux là et finalement avec avec le
recul désormais je pense que le golf en
tant que discipline qui a besoin
justement d'exposition doit pouvoir
s'inspirer de la de la popularité du
foot
la difficulté actuelle c'est de partager
le terrain c'est à dire que quentin
quand un terrain de foot gueule s'ouvre
c'est sur un terrain traditionnel de
gauche 9e 9 ou 18 trous avec des
gamelles qui sont beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus grande
je parlais trop plu plus important c'est
ça et il faut quasiment quasiment fermé
le parcours pour l'ouvrir au football
selon ses dires qui est le partage est
actuellement à sens unique on ne peut
pas faire vidéo discipline en même temps
en revanche ça apporte une petite aura
et une est un petit peu de visibilité au
gulf ça se commence à se jouer aussi au
rugby et du rugby golf et du disque au
golf c'est à dire qu'en gros là on est
en train de tenter plein d'activités
autour du golf avec avec un autre à un
autre outil une autre balle et ça donne
ça donne des compétitions assez assez
convivial sympa spectaculaire maintenant
c'est le
le succès de l'opération c'est de savoir
comment les comment les parcours de golf
vont réussir à partager leur espace avec
les fous de golfeurs et c'est vrai qu'il
ya tellement de parcours de golf dans
les yvelines que certains peuvent tenter
l'expérience
mais pour l'instant il n'ya pas
malheureusement de structure vraiment
pour pour accueillir le foot golfe
il y en a 10 à saint son nom à croissy
sur seine et il y en a également à la
limite des yvelines en essonne dans un
golf blue green c'est ça c'est un taux
bas dans l'essonne c'est à côté
elle et ses enfants dehors de l'ipad le
nigeria février sur la route de la
maison ça vous donne envie de pratiquer
cette discipline n'ont clairement pas
tomber alors comme j'ai déjà dit moi mon
père à pratiquer le golf
je sais pas s'ils jouent encore mais il
m'assure dumazy surtout ne commence pas
parce que l'on sera réduit non mais mais
il m'a dit surtout ne commence pas parce
que tu me connais il sait comment je
suis et je vais être mordu mordu
maintenant je suis pas assez techniques
footballistiques mans en fait voilà je
suis bon avec mes pieds mais quand il
faut appuyer sur les pédales n'est pas
pour taper dans un ballon et donc je
suis pas sûr ce sont un truc qui se fait
pour moi
après c'est pareil ça prend énormément
de temps d'aller faire un parcours de
golf ça d'apprendre le même temps que ce
soit pour du foot golf ou pour du golfe
voilà c'est plus courts plus rapides
plus petits pots les plus dynamiques
parce que ta pote à moi il ya moins de
technique d'accord mais maintenant voilà
je pense que l'idée est bonne parce que
c'est vrai que on voit que il ne joue
pas sur le sur le green y joue juste
surfer oui joue juste à côté les trous
sont pas au même endroit
et donc voilà ça ne détruit pas le
parcours de golf et donc ça peut être ça
peut ça peut ça peut coller mais
rapidement on va laisser le mot de la
fin à une femme pour la saint valentin
hélène est ce que vous seriez capable de
jouer à ce sport en fait je pense que
j'aime pas non je trouve que c'est une
espèce de conte et locaux de la forme
qu'elle goff uncle golf ou que le foot
mais les deux ça fait un peu je sais pas
quoi faire avec mes jambes chez
maladroit alors je fais des gros
troupeau essaie de faire quelque chose
les jouer au golf ou midi c'était le mot
la fin on va terminer cette émission par
une citation d'un boxeur jake dance est
champion du monde poids lourds de 1919 à
1926 un champion c'est quelqu'un qui se
relève quand il ne peut pas se relever
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 70 10
[Musique]